and one welcome to 30 playing Karloff w
you color room yeah come on probably
some ratty system okay yeah that gives
me a big share of the center it's not
how you play the Queen's Indian usually
wow are you serious
yeah well why did why this better know
in many ways can take or can play this
should age 6 I don't know night eh fine
maybe I should have thought about this a
bit longer yeah because g6 night back
and f5 kind of belongs into this okay
let the together structure so bad for
black you can also go back it's a bit
poison stupid term it's a bit weird down
but simply you never have the bishop on
b7 in such a position it just does not
really work so and f5 I would like to go
F for new a loss to tempe with them with
a bad night h4 move
okay so five is closed when he really
close to working no I don't know that it
was even move earlier it was interesting
see it gets really really interesting
okay so i have looked at six now or
bishop f6 a bishop f6
yeah we got six is the rook is wrong on
the square but it is a very sadly nice
tempo to gain I can you go to the seven
I guess we should have success also
Bishop c4 okay twenty seven will be
played and I'll see what happens here
[Music]
she said objectively good for me maybe
maybe not I just wanted to punish a clip
on this year and probably it was a bit
too much
I'm pretty sure bedroom and e2 is doing
we taking a two that's amazing and now
it's got the F poor lady
[Music]
maybe you could have played the F pawn
yeah I don't know it will be some wild
finish probably with the time ticking
down
check okay I'll just got queen a four
and he wins with the mating attack and
would be would be really really cool yes
ok so I'm can I do this you'll probably
take on age to check
that's may be very risky but I don't
want I just want to try to win with Ruby
70m I don't maybe he can do something
like like this for Queen D 1
if if i move the bush line morning queen
da does something here I move the bishop
here threatening queen the aid and then
rookie seven so you cannot play Queen
you one
probably he will take them and queen you
one for some mayhem check can't if I go
here check on the three check on g4
takes takes takes their think that it
should win but the f I don't have time
check don't understand Jeter could have
done that with without okay without that
check check it's a picture box chain
what am I doing here the rookie 6
unbelievable I'm really really doing
weird stuff like forfeit on time wow
really really doing weird moves all over
the place it is just pretty bad old
indian and see' hi fi mean really
everything is misplaced i am
nith for isn't good probably the engine
actually stood gives me a big advantage
no but I don't know I just probably
wanted to punish it too hard this
doesn't doesn't fully work you know it
looks active but it's it's not it's not
cleaning young knight h5 and this is
given as winning by the engine it's very
scary for a human to play this this
thing but this this and then I have
ideas that it won't be easy and then now
India now is on roughly equal
interesting yeah i mean in blitz chest
you can try those things I mean this is
just extremely cheeky take the a blonde
[Music]
ok form and they were probably tons of
mistakes in this game push it takes a
stronger can Mazen night h5 here okay
okay and this definitely was risky I hi
f-4s an orphan who takes could you for
check songs it's okay supposed to be
roughly equal anything can happen there
and he I'm gonna have to push of age 6
k-j oh yeah could have done a king f2
was better now
yeah okay but I saw that cringy for
would win basically the same as in the
game it just g5 gave me just the porn
for nothing okay but you enter on and on
the seventh rank and bring everything
but what am i doing yeah like Bishop is
safe it's like currently I'm kind of in
suicidal mow down somehow i was thinking
like I can take on b6 and when mountain
why not check him close they were they
said bishop I mean really strange okay
thanks for watching